so tivity cool toys in your room you
want to show me
do you know Captain America I've got his
action figure but I lost the shield so I
know one hey everybody its charlie
hopefully you've had a chance to watch
at least a little bit of Jessica Jones
season 2 this is gonna be my
non-spoilery review of the season if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
there's so much Marvel stuff happening
between infinity war the Deadpool movie
and the Deadpool TV series so I'll
compare it to some of the other Marvel
Netflix series because now that we're at
the point where they're all getting
multiple seasons you see is evidence
from Jessica Jones Season 2 that they
all will have very different tones we're
getting three new Marvel Netflix series
this year Jessica Jones was the first
one Luke Cage is dropping in June and
then daredevil is gonna drop later this
year and after you watch a little bit of
Jessica Jones you'll see that they're
designed to be very very different
so unlike the Marvel films where you
kind of know what you're getting into
when you see that Marvel logo like okay
you know some of this is gonna be a
little serious there'll be some humor
some heroics some really crazy special
effects scenes Thor strongest Avenger
strongest Avenger Point Break Jessica
Jones season 2 is designed to be more of
a character study in dealing with trauma
so like everybody gets a character arc
Malcolm Jessica Trish jeryn hogarth they
all get really strong arcs but they
don't wind up leaving you in the same
place that most Marvel movies leave you
or even like a daredevil series which is
more traditionally a superhero series so
the marble Netflix series just in
general are designed to be aggressively
real-world like we're trying to do
really dark gritty real world drama
about real people living in a superhero
world so they do tangentially reference
stuff that's happening in the movies
every once in a while I got a lot of
questions on Twitter about that what
about the way they casually referenced
Captain America or the stuff that was
happening during civil war or things
like the raft yes their ways
Jessica Jones sort of paints itself into
the larger Marvel Universe in based on
some of the references they make it
actually seems like the timeline of this
is taking place during 2016 and not in
present day but Jessica herself sort of
shrugs off a lot of the trappings of a
classic superhero so if you're looking
for Marvel superhero TV like if you're
looking for classic entertaining marvel
that'll make you feel better about
yourself at the end this is not that
kind of superhero series in fact I think
the people that had the most triumphant
arcs during the series were Malcolm in
jeryn hogarth
in the way it paints all those victories
in the characters at the end almost
seems like a twisted version of the end
of civil war where like the team has
broken apart but they still have the
phone to contact each other if you ever
need me Tony call me so even though
Captain America and Iron Man still have
beef with each other you know that
they're still going to be helping each
other out that is not the case with the
Jessica Jones characters it's almost an
anti superhero series in that sense so
it's like yeah all that really awesome
stuff that happened during those big
movies we're not doing any of that
there is a plot point that helps
populate the universe with some more
potential supers down the road if they
want to roll them out so there is a
little bit of like superhero stuff
happening on the street level because
there are only a couple characters that
genuinely have powers in the Marvel
Netflix series all the mains even
daredevil kind of has a special ability
now it seems like they're building
themselves room for more potential like
traditional superheroes to populate the
universe people with powers but again
the series is really all about Jessica's
arc dealing with her past so if you're
not a big fan of the jessica jones
character or some of the tropes of that
series then you are probably not gonna
like season 2 like if you weren't down
for season 1 you really won't be down
for season 2 because it is probably the
most jessica jones that jessica jones
could be but whereas season 1 had this
amazing central villain David Tennant
made that series Krysten Ritter David
Tennant together really were what drove
that there's none of that during season
2 so that's one of the bigger weaknesses
that a lot of people point to like the
lack of a real central villain there is
an antagonist during the season but it
isn't what you would call a traditional
big bad that the hero has to sort of
level up either psychologically
or physically in order to defeat so
because the series is sort of diverging
in this very different tone very
different direction from the other
Netflix series I think that's why they
decided to drop the Luke Cage season 2
teaser separately instead of his opposed
credit scene at the end of episode 13
like the way they've done in the past
like they drop the Punisher teaser at
the end of defenders
speaking of which she watched 13 hours
of this you wait to the end but that
something special and there's nothing
there there is a resolution to the
series it gives you a pretty good idea
of where they're gonna pick up in season
3 I definitely think they're gonna get a
season 3 because again Netflix has
almost unlimited money so it's not
really a problem for them to greenlight
series and you can clearly see from just
the way they put the show together that
it does not cost a lot of money compared
to other traditional superhero series so
it's not like it's gonna get cancelled
for low viewership but again it's one of
those times when Netflix doesn't openly
report numbers because people just like
slowly start watching the series it's
not like daredevil where everybody just
barrels in that opening weekend holy
crap we got to see what our favorite
character is doing so I can't say enough
about Krysten Ritter she's really like
the secret sauce of the series like
she's fantastic all the other main
actors also great performances but again
is a big fan of the comic book medium of
comic book stories characters I couldn't
help but feel a little underwhelmed and
a lot of that is due to the fact that
Marvel movies are now turning into the
new television there's 22 Marvel movies
after Avengers 4 there are 22 episodes
in a typical season of television so
when you look at a platform like Netflix
and you just have a bunch of thumbnails
that are right next to each other you
have Doctor Strange you have a Civil War
and then Sandwich between them is a
season of Jessica Jones what is the
average Marvel fan gonna click on like
they're gonna re-watch Civil War for the
tenth time rather than sit through 13
hours of Jessica Jones making you feel
terrible about yourself
trash bag so I feel like that's a big
challenge for Marvel TV going forward
but I feel like daredevil is up to that
so if you're like a classic Marvel
superhero fan daredevil is probably
going to be your series this year but
again that Luke Cage season 2 teaser
trailer they're doing Heroes for Hire
it seems like Luke Cage is also sort of
getting off the stoop like it's pushing
more in the superhero direction and less
in the Jessica Jones direction so if you
have any questions about the characters
or plot points just write them below in
the comments let me know what you
thought of it once you have a chance to
watch a couple episodes I'm really
hoping that future seasons wind up being
like 10 episodes or eight episodes
because this didn't feel like it needed
13 hours to tell the story that it told
really hoping that they use more for
traditional PI story for next season
like they just have her solving cases in
every episode and some of those allow
her to cross over with the other Netflix
heroes but what'll happen is tonight is
there supposed to be some new infinity
war footage to the dropping I'll do a
video for that there's a new legends of
tomorrow so I'll just post updates on
the video schedule on Twitter and in
that top pin comment click here for some
behind the scenes infinity war and to
watch me unbox that giant Infinity
Gauntlet toy and click here for my
breakdown at that soul gem provo thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight